welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on forensic science
a multidisciplinary approach it is my
pleasure to introduce to you dr. Linda
Birnbaum dr. Birnbaum is a director of
the National Institute of Environmental
Health Sciences and the National
Institutes of Health and the National
Toxicology program she is a
board-certified toxicologists and has
served as a federal scientist for nearly
39 years prior to her current
appointment she spent 19 years of the US
Environmental Protection Agency for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. Birnbaum keynote
presentation is titled health impacts of
environment chemical exposures my name
is Christie Joel and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presenter labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is education on FS offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to a to your credit now without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Linda Birnbaum I will now turn the
presentation over to her hello everyone
my name is Linda Birnbaum and I'm
director of the National Institute of
Environmental Health Sciences in the
National Toxicology program I'm here to
tell you a little bit today about the
health and
of environmental chemical exposures
first just in case some of you are not
for low your with what is NIH it is the
largest and the primary federal agency
for conducting and supporting biomedical
research in the United States and
actually around the world our budget in
2019 is more than thirty nine billion
dollars which is invested annually and
we are funding well over three hundred
thousand researchers around the country
in every state and around the world
now ni EHS which is the Institute of
which I'm the director is one of 27
National Institutes of Health
Institute's and we are the only one
which is located in Research Triangle
Park North Carolina instead of in
Bethesda Maryland we support a wide
variety of programs supporting our
mission just like any NIH Institute we
have our two vibrant intramural
laboratory programs one focused on basic
biomedical research and the other
looking at looking at toxicology issues
which is actually a cross-departmental
program which involves CDC and FDA as
well by getting NIH Institute we have a
clinical research program on-site and we
most of our money goes out to fund
grants around the world what makes this
unique in addition to our location is
that our focus is very much on disease
prevention and Public Health because if
we understand what it is in our
environment that causes disease
hopefully we can do something about it
so when we talk about our health people
often assume or go right away to the
idea that everything in our health is
determined by our genes but I think we
all know that it's not that simple and
that in fact our health is a combination
of our genes and our environment and
here at NIH s we define our environment
very broadly to include not only
synthetic chemicals that might be used
for example in agriculture or in our
consumer products or things that are
admitted by industry the tailpipes and
go into our air or our water but also
things like the medicines that we take
the food that we eat the stress that we
all live under and for example many
personal care products all of these
things can have impacts upon our health
a realization that's hit us very
strongly within the past couple of years
is that a good start last a lifetime and
unfortunately so does bad start and
we're understanding that things that
affect our development very early in
life including before conception but
certainly in the womb during infancy and
childhood in our reproductive years and
so on can have impacts on our health
later on and this is a whole new field
called the developmental origins of
health and disease
we're also understanding that when we
talk toxicology which is really the
science of safety is that much of the
idea that how much you are exposed to or
your dose makes the poison
comes from a statement that Paracelsus
made about 500 years ago we know today
that it's more than just the dose it's
also the timing and the accrued versus
chronic nature and where you are in your
life stage that can make a difference
but the dose does play a relationship to
what the effects that we're going to see
now when you're dealing with forensic
toxicology you're often dealing with
acute poisonings and you're dealing
sometimes with lethal effects but when
we're dealing with impacts of
environmental exposure on our health
we're often focusing on things that
happen at low doses and often exposures
that occur repeatedly or in a chronic
niche so as I said a minute ago dose is
not the only concern but a factors such
as our genes which help determine our
susceptibility whether we're mayor male
or female when in our life it occurs and
the microbiome plays a role in a
susceptibility
so when we talk about forensic
toxicology and environmental health how
that kind of differs from what we're
doing with environmental health research
forensic toxicology is focused on
helping the medical and the legal
professions deal with certain issues but
environmental health we're really trying
to understand how the environment
affects our health to inform disease
prevention but there are many things
that are similar between the two fields
first in both cases we're going to be
collecting preparing and storing tests
and Barry's bio samples we want to store
them so that they're stable we have to
all think about the dose and when the
timing of the exposures and where the
exposure comes from both in forensic
toxicology and environmental health we
have to think about how long the
chemical hangs around in our bodies
whether repeated exposure is going to
build up what dose in our body the
bioaccumulation issue and whether the
chemical to which we're exposed in the
environment is actually transformed when
it gets into our body into something
else but while we have certain
differences we are also looking at
similar ways of screening and measuring
some of the exposures and some of the
early responses to exposures so we may
be using GC mass spec or high resolution
mass spec or NMR for example and for bio
responses we may be looking at cytokines
we may be running various amino acids
immunoassays there are different things
that we want to do what's become
absolutely clear is that when we're
studying Public Health it is absolutely
essential that we integrate the tools
and the results we find from
epidemiology data with those that we
find from toxicology data which in terms
of experimental toxicology is usually
dealing with animals or in vitro or in
silico or computational kinds of data
and that we absolutely need these
interdisciplinary collaborations in
order to understand
parts of our environment on health so
I'm gonna give a number of examples
these are in no way complete but they're
hopefully to just give you a taste of
the some of the things that we are
interested in when we're studying
environmental health and the impact on
people so first I'm gonna go through a
little bit we're about water then I'm
gonna talk about air then I'm gonna talk
about food and I'm gonna talk about soil
so when we talking when we talk about
what's in our water there are lots of
things in our water and things that we
can know there can be pesticides there
can be micro different kinds of bugs or
viruses we can have things like plastics
we can have the chemicals known as pee
fast which I'll talk about later we can
have things like lead I think everyone
is familiar of the tragic situation in
Flint Michigan of a couple of years ago
and we can have many other compounds in
our waters such as mercury but this is
again it's just a tidbit or tapping the
surface of what might be in our water
and I'm going to give you some examples
um I'm gonna start off with arsenic
poisoning because drinking arsenic
contaminated with drinking water is a
major problem in several parts of the
world but it's actually a problem even
where I come from in North Carolina and
arsenic some of you may be familiar with
the the play Arsenic and Old Lace in
which they these lovely old ladies are
busy putting gentlemen callers out of
their misery by give them high levels of
arsenic but the poisoning by arsenic is
not limited to two tales stories and
tales and it is also going to occur in
real life and unfortunately again here
in North Carolina we've had several
recent incidences of both murder and
poisoning by by family members
Blanche more actually dispatched of I
believe it was four husbands and one
boyfriend survived her attempts and she
was caught there was another tragic
incident here where a young woman
poisoned her her husband with arsenic
and and he did not survive so very high
levels of arsenic can lead to fatalities
but we know that at lower levels of
effects there are many different things
that arsenic can cause arsenic is a
naturally occurring element and I concur
both in organic and inorganic forms and
there's a whole variety of health
effects for example at high levels of
exposure it's associated with cancer in
the skin the bladder the law also the
kidney
probably the liver there are effects on
the brain both developmental and in
adults there is effects on the immune
system there are effects on our
respiratory system there are effects on
our hormonal systems am arsenic can act
like in an exogenous estrogen and as
I've already mentioned high doses can be
associated with death now in a study
that we've been carrying on from was 20
years or I should say our grantees from
Columbia University have been studying a
cohort of thirty five thousand people in
Bangladesh this is an example of good
attention with gone awry where w-h-o in
the 1970s put in pumps to get to ground
water which was uncontaminated by
microbes unfortunately and unknown w-h-o
at the time this ground water was
heavily contaminated with naturally
occurring arsenic and it took over ten
years before people began to report
examples of arsenic toxicity but
following people now for the last twenty
years we've been able to observe some of
the adverse effects in this population
of increase in mortality problems in
cognition and motor function in children
effects on the heart and the walls and
effects on skin lesions which you saw in
the last picture in the last slide now
the effects that are occurring in
Bangladesh at very high concentrations
have also been observed in Maine where
our grantees have looked at the IQ of
children who have spent their
essentially their entire life and named
in most cases on well water and we know
that there's naturally occurring arsenic
in the water in
and what they were able to show that
children with higher arsenic exposure
showed a reduction in IQ points now this
is not you can't pick this up on an
individual basis but you can pick it up
in a population of children and find
that those drinking higher arsenic
levels and this was only the levels that
they were drinking was only five cards
for Jeff art five parts per billion
which is within the maximum contaminant
level that has been set by US EPA
the levels that EPA has set is ten parts
per billion so this is really increasing
our level of concern for arsenic at low
levels of exposure we're also finding
associations in a variety of
Epidemiology studies and there's some
animal data to provide
biological plausibility that there's an
association between high arsenic
exposure and increased risk of type 2
diabetes this is especially true of
individuals who are overweight or
actually obese overweight is usually
considered a BMI greater than 25 and
obesity greater than 30 and the findings
really support a synergism ongoing
between the risk of type 2 diabetes I
think most of us know that overweight is
a risk factor but exposure to arsenic
increases that risk as well
now we're also finding that low levels
of arsenic are associated with immune
suppression and this can be picked up in
response to bacteria this is Pseudomonas
aeruginosa which can be a bacteria that
can colonize the lung and this
suppresses our immune responses
monitored by secretion of cytokines and
if we look at MMA which is one organic
form of arsenic and actually we're
understanding that MMA can be the most
toxic form of arsenic what we can see is
a complete difference with a lot of more
cytokines produced by the by as a result
of bacterial infection but then we
actually get a decrease in that with the
exposure to MMA at very low doses
now I mentioned that we can see effects
related to early life exposure and
unfortunately there's a classic study of
this that happened in northern QA up in
the Atacama Desert an affogato is a
fairly large city in which people were
exposed to high levels of arsenic in
their drinking water from 1958 to 1970
and this was because there are many
compromises in that area and they were
using they rerouted the route River to
run through the copper mines to wash out
debris from the mines but then 50 miles
downstream
it was the water drinking water supply
for this city and unfortunately what we
found is that for people who were
exposed during this time you can see
that there are Senate concentration and
these people changed well this is
actually concentration in the water
change increased dramatically because of
the water source and we did find that
people who were exposed early in life to
arsenic especially in utero or in
childhood had an increased risk of
several kinds of cancer type 2 diabetes
and hypertension so this is actually
showing you that it took 40 years to go
to have the 40 years of exposure okay
I'm sorry
arson exposure started to increase in
around 1958 and it peaked in about 1970
but you can see that lung cancer which
is associated with this increase in
arsenic has a very long mortality
latency before more you find the disease
and it was in about 40 years so what we
can find is that the time of high
exposure you have a almost a 40 year
risk before you see the increase in
cancer in the population what we're
seeing in our human studies again we
have biological plausibility that
support this in from our animal studies
if my mice are exposed starting in utero
so before birth as well as throughout
their life to arsenic in the drinking
water what you find
at a dose of fifty parts-per-million and
remember I mentioned that the regulatory
limited in the u.s. is ten parts per
billion we are finding a very
significant increase in lung tumors in
the mice and this is true both in males
and female but we actually see benign
tumors things like adenoma as opposed to
carcinomas occurring at the lower
concentration and females as well and an
interesting thing here is at the very
high concentration of 5000 parts per
billion we do not see a significant
increase in cancer and part of that is
because the mice have other problems
that they may die before they develop
the tumors so that was just giving you
an example of something in water which
can cause a problem I want to go over
some of the things that are in the air
we breathe that are problematic for our
health and these are a variety of things
I think people are familiar with the
regulatory levels or that we might have
on ozone or on for example particulate
matter but in addition we can have
biologics in our air things like mold we
have smoke and I think people are
familiar with the secondhand smoke issue
we can have volatile organic chemicals
things like formaldehyde and we can have
gases as well things like sulfur dioxide
and nitrous oxide as well and of course
things like asbestos and allergens can
also be present in our air so the answer
I'm going to focus on are summer outdoor
and indoor air exposures or outdoor
exposures are what we regulate we do not
regulate our indoor exposures which may
be problematic but in our outdoor air we
can be exposed to vehicle emissions and
industrial emissions are things work
always concerned with ozone is is
generated when we have lots of work
generates smog I should say we have
particulate matter
we have polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons
known human carcinogens and we can have
things like dioxins as well on outdoors
we have many similar products that we
have indoors like for example
particulate matter and PAH is and so on
but we also things like mold and dust we
have the vapours that we get from
cleaning products we have flame
retardants and a whole variety of
different kind of chemicals indoors so
when we talk about air pollution and
health
we know that approximately 8 million
people a year worldwide actually die
from air pollution and while the
majority of those are in our low and
middle income countries it is also a
problem in our country as well of the
deaths from pollution it's approximately
half in half that about 4.2 million are
related to outdoor air pollution and
close to 4 million are associated with
indoor air pollution especially related
to cook stoves using biofuels as their
as their as their fuel source I think we
need to realize that while most air
pollution deaths are related to non
communicable chronic diseases such as
cancer and stroke and heart disease and
other kinds of lung disease never mind
type-2 diabetes and obesity but I think
it's important to that morbidity um
worldwide is also related to non more
related to non communicable rather than
infectious disease today so some of you
may have heard about the London smog
epidemic which occurred or episode which
occurred my goodness over 60 65 over 65
years ago there have been similar
episodes that have occurred in Belgium
and in Donora Pennsylvania area and in
other parts of the world but what
happened was the London smog there was
an air inversion at the time in the in
the wintertime and there was an air
inversion and much of their heating and
electricity generation was being done by
coal at the time and as many as 4,000
people died during this during this
errand air episode many died from
influenza which again increased in part
because of the suppression of the immune
system like I mentioned with with
arsenic before but
other reasons also many people died they
didn't know why and what you see here in
the light blue bar is that um when the
government estimates following in that
winter related to the smog was a
tremendous increase in the amount of
mortality now I can I can say this is
not unique to London I mentioned several
other episodes we even every time there
is really bad air pollution in a city or
a dense air eret we see an increase in
hospital visits and death which are
associated with the heavy air pollution
so we're also finding that it's not only
acute mortality but we're also finding
that there are effects on the developing
fetus so that we can see there's a clear
association between between particulate
matter exposure during pregnancy and
decreased birth weights and you can see
this both when we're looking for example
things like elemental carbon and sulfur
or from looking at some of the different
metals that have this effect and this is
more pronounced when an exposure is
later in pregnancy and some some of our
components for example something like
vanadium has a very dramatic effect on
on the weight of the baby now we also
know that asthma increases both the
induction of asthma and then
exacerbations in other words people have
more asthma attacks that are associated
with air pollution and I we've known for
a while and have more and more data that
shows that you live close to a major
roadway within 200 meters you there's an
increased incident and persists or
there's a risk of increased incidence
and persistence of asthma and that this
occurs not just during early life
exposure such as childhood but can also
occur in adult life so actually this
Malati study is following a longitudinal
cohort of 45 people in Tasmania that
they followed for eight years and showed
that you have people becoming a
Manek in that timeframe associated with
the greater exposure to PM 2.5 and to
black carbon as well and this is on your
left on your screen is the what's
happening in children and that there is
also the association that we are seeing
in adults as well so what else is
happening to children in in addition be
more at risk for low birth weight being
more at risk for asthma
there's also effects on learning memory
and behavior in children and this this
is a study just showing the association
with an increased risk at the higher
levels of air pollution exposure attics
are what are formed by PAHs they
actually bind to the DNA and can be
measured for example in the cord blood
of the mothers so that we know that this
is associated with in utero exposure and
you can see with higher levels of adult
formation there is a greater risk of
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
we also know that with exposure to other
kinds of air pollution not only the PAHs
are present on the particulate matter
but with nitrous oxides we see impacts
on learning and memory as well and one
thing ought to point out here make them
back to later is that we often see six
specific or sex dependent effects
sometimes males are more sensitive
sometimes females are more sensitive so
I often say that's just veal our
difference but I think again we're also
seeing associations of this
traffic-related air pollution being
associated with increased risk of
depression and anxiety so affects both
on learning and memory and on behavioral
endpoints now this is just some
concerning data we you know I think many
of you are aware of the dramatic
increase in children on the autism
spectrum I should say people on the
autism spectrum which has increased from
about one in a hundred and twenty to one
in 59 at the last CDC studies but what
you can see here depending upon the
different measures that are used in
almost
all cases exposure to and again this is
traffic related pollution is associated
with an increased risk of a child being
on the autism spectrum and this is
related to maternal and very neat early
neonatal exposure there are many more
studies looking at air pollution and
finding this relationship but something
that I wanted to point out is that we
see that this is consistent in multiple
studies although within a given study
there may be some differences now where
it's not only early in life in age that
a particulate matter is a problem but we
know that there is growing evidence for
particulate matter being associated with
neurodegenerative diseases as well both
for all kinds of dementia for
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's disease so
in this study they looked at almost 10
million subjects from 50 US cities and
this is the data for the 50 cities and
what you can see if you put all the data
together there's a clear statistically
significant increased risk of
Alzheimer's disease as the particulate
matter levels increase and this is just
some data with Parkinson's disease and
this is looking in this case at the
nitrous oxides and what again what you
can see if you look at the curve is the
increased risk higher odds ratio of
developing Parkinson's disease in
association to traffic-related air
pollution now I mentioned that I have a
lot of concerns with household air
pollution which is largely much of it is
related to cooking with open fires and
biomass stoves it could be coal it could
be dung could be wood but also kerosene
and the estimates before I giving you an
estimate of 3.8 million
w-h-o recently estimated four point
three million deaths associated with
household air pollution and these
associations we find in the women an
increased blood pressure related to
their carbon monoxide exposure getting
out of these there's also lots of data
with a particulate matter I think we're
talking about this indoor cook stove
exposure we women and children are
disproportionately exposed children have
a higher risk of pneumonia related to
this exposure and women are at increased
risk for example of lung cancer in
addition even in our country there are
studies coming out of the NIH s sister
study showing that indoor wood-burning
either once a week is associated with a
higher risk of breast cancer from women
in the US and we do have many of our
rural and tribal populations are doing
quite a bit of wood burning and I think
this raises some concern we also
understand that I talked about air
pollution from namely particulates and
some gases but things like gasoline
vapors can also be acutely fatal and
this is just some studies showing that a
man went into a control room with the
transporting unleaded fuel and he
actually died from the exposure that he
had to a variety of things from the
vapors I think at least in the past
levels of benzene and your gasoline
could be as high as 5% it's lower now
but this just shows some of the data of
the levels that were in the the person
who died from exposure to in this
control room to unleaded fuel the vapors
of it and they believe that this person
died very very rapidly now benzene I
think people are well aware that this is
a dangerous chemical but we do form it
naturally just hopefully not very much
it is used in closed processes and many
in the many industries but it can also
escape into the air and where it can be
used as a solvent in variety of
industries
the major route of exposure is
inhalation although there can be some
ingestion if benzene is in your water or
in some of your food benzene is a known
human carcinogen we've had evidence for
that for for close to 100 years now and
in addition to causing especially
different kinds blood cancers it is also
associated with effects on our
cardiovascular system our neurological
system and again effects on the immune
system so looking at some of this data
what we can see is is the increased risk
of all leukemias associated with benzene
exposure and this is whether it's acute
lymphoblastic or acute myeloid leukemia
think one thing if if you look at the
dose response curves here what you can
see is the greatest effect is happening
at the lowest levels of exposure where
you have a very steep dose response
curve we know that there's a higher risk
for childhood leukemia when the parents
are exposed to benzene and as I
mentioned related to smoke at both
smokers and non-smokers there's an
increased risk of heart disease and we
did find an increased risk of
neurological symptoms of residents who
were exposed or who exposed in the Gulf
states - for example the Gulf oil spill
of 2010 so switching away from air and
water to what's in our food again
unfortunately sometimes we have
bacterial viral contamination we have
all kinds of different contaminants that
can get into our food either because of
the growing of the food the conditions
under which it's grown or how the plants
or the animals are water for example or
sometimes related to transfer from
containers in which food is still stored
so as I just said our food can be
contaminated by our natural environment
arsenic for example is the problem or
can be a problem if rice is grown in
areas where arsenic is present we can
have for example microbes from our
natural environment pesticides or PCBs
but I also mentioned food packaging and
so things like BPA which has been
removed from baby bottles and sippy cups
but BPA and it substitutes are still
present another food contact material
violates
the current poly fluorinated alkyl
substances which are of growing concern
in our country and around the world
there's a whole variety that of effects
that can be associated with exposure to
where food contaminants and again varies
depending on the contaminant you're
talking about it and the inherent
susceptibility of who's exposed so I've
mentioned the P phase substances and I
think our concern is growth for these
because they are produced in very very
high amounts they have now led to
contamination worldwide including the
Arctic where they were never used there
are thousands of them with more being
developed and produced all the time they
move through the environment and
basically these are known as forever
chemicals they will never leave the
environment the carbon fluorine bond is
probably one of the strongest bonds that
exists in nature
we're using them or they can develop
because they provide resistance to
grease and water and oil so they've been
used in to make our frying pans and our
raincoats and our hiking boots and many
other important uses but they're also
being used in many food contact
materials and there are alternatives the
the top to the P folks and the P FOA I
have actually their production has been
has stopped in the United States but
their alternatives for example like this
Gen X there has been very little
information available on it I will say
that as we study some of the
alternatives if if they are a PFS member
we're finding that they do many of the
same things that P foes and pathology so
P phase health effects that has again
the laundry list of health effects
including endocrine disruption
specifically the thyroid here we also
see the increased risk associated with P
foes and increased risk of diabetes and
with PF na which is similar to the PFOA
I mentioned before that hate-crimes this
has nine carbons and what we're seeing
here again is an impact on executive
functioning that's base
learning and memory in children related
to their early life exposure again it's
early life this is part of the issue
I mentioned that food packaging
materials can contain peat bass and the
study was done two years ago which
showed that almost half of food contact
papers and many paper board samples
contain PFS that was actually validated
by going into a subset of the hundreds
of samples that they looked at to see
what kinds of PFS they were and there
were many that have not previously been
reported but while a lot of the focus on
PFS has focused on what's in our water
we are now understanding that what's in
our food may be a major contributor to
what's in our bodies the other component
or group of compounds I wanted to
mention in our food are the phthalates
and this is a huge group of chemicals
that are often used to make plastics
more soft and flexible many of you may
remember rubber ducky that used to have
certain kinds of ballast in them those
phalates are no longer being used but we
have alternatives alternative phalates
and again like the PFF story we are
finding that the alternatives may be
problematic as well now I mentioned the
food the food contact materials deh P
diethyl hexa phthalates is one of the
main families that is present and
contaminating our food from those
sources and again not only do they come
from the packaging but also the
processing and handling same in the
factories again a long list of health
effects including effects on our
endocrine system an acute occluding
effects for example here increased risk
of developing ADHD related to in utero
diethyl have diethyl phthalate exposure
we're also finding that prenatal
exposure is associated with the
increased risk of overweight so again
deh p increased risk of increased BMI so
to some of the other related phthalates
and one of the things that has been
shown
repeatedly in animal studies and a human
studies that exposure to phthalates can
act in an anti-angiogenic number we see
effects on the developing male
reproductive system which is maintained
into adulthood and we also see that the
sperm produced in this case are less
mobile which is a problem related to
fertility where are we getting family so
again it often in food packaging but
where do we find this to be very
problematic especially related to fast
food intake so for example what you can
see here is especially for example
children again because children eat more
per body per their size than adults do
what we can see that intake of
phthalates is associated with higher
levels than adults in adolescence but
what we can see here also is the
increase levels with no phthalates in
adults and adolescents middle levels of
phthalates and high levels I'm sorry a
fast food and we infer from that
actually and have measured the levels of
a family in their urine so I mentioned
that rubber ducky is no longer has the
same family siddhim years ago for
example it used to have something like
DEP and that's been replaced by these
dibp
and you can see that when you a
regulation goes into effect you see a
dramatic decline in the levels of that
valley in the urine of people who might
be exposed and you see an increase in
the replacement valleys in the urine of
exposed people now I did want to mention
the kinds of exposures environmental
exposures we would have from our land
soil and settlement and again you see
some of the favorite actors coming back
arsenic mercury pesticides dioxin PAH is
all kinds of metals and so on so there
was a pesticide poisoning and I'm trying
to use some examples that I think are
very relevant to forensic toxicologist
this was a young boy poisoned by social
fluoride which is a pesticide it was
used to fumigate his home and the child
entered when he was when the family was
told it was safe unfortunately this
child was poisoned by the residual
fluoride in his in his home and he
suffered severe brain damage
and obviously that became a case for the
courts but this is an example with a
high dose exposure to this chemical was
very problematic now we also know that
pesticide exposure whether it's a
herbicide a fungicide or insecticide or
a disinfectant there are many sources of
exposure that can be agricultural and so
if you're a farm worker you can be
exposed or if you live near a farm but
some agricultural things of course
remain on our food I could be things
that we use in our homes or it could be
occupational and there are many health
effects associated with exposure
including cancer neurological effects
endocrine effects and death even at very
high levels so this was I think an
important study looking at the effects
of organophosphate pesticides and this
was namely chlorpyrifos and what they
saw here was they there's children
aren't that often they can actually be
involved in some of the field work in
Ecuador but certainly their parents
bring it home them on their clothes and
if you look at your Mother's Day what
you can see is an increase problems in
children's behavior associated with the
exposure that the tremendous floral
production and that was used related to
the production of large numbers of
flowers for for Mother's Day and so we
believe that there are effects on the
children's nor a behavior now I actually
want to go back to this again because
there's lots of evidence that this is
this is exposure when the children are
young children we also know that
exposure to identify state pesticides in
utero
is associated with lower IQ in the
children so there's where I mentioned
that air pollution is associated with
increased risk of autism we're also
finding again the beauty of longitudinal
epidemiology studies the observational
studies have so much power when they're
done longitudinally and in the study
that was conducted in Finland they are
able to show that mothers who had the
highest levels of dde early in their
pregnancy were more likely to have a
child who developed autism and didi he
is the major metabolite
that is produced by from DDT exposure
now I mentioned the organophosphate
exposure and again chlorpyrifos and the
IQ but it's also related to decreased
motor function so what you can hear is
that there are impacts for example with
those who are most highly exposed to to
gross movement fine moon income
composite movement as well in this study
this was done in China and they compared
the motor functions of neonates with
nine month old Chinese infants and they
found exposure not only to poor purifies
that nail it which some of you may
remember is the pesticide the
organophosphate pesticide that was
recommended for use for Zika spring was
associated with impacts on motor
function this is some of the data the
animal data which supports what's been
observed in observational human studies
which that exposing rats during most of
their this is gestation day seven to
postnatal day 21 is associated and with
quite low doses actually is associated
with neural inflammation in the brains
of the neonates and this is again
associated with exposure what's called
the perinatal period during gestation
and throughout lactation and the
interesting the really interesting thing
here is that the effects were
sex-specific they were more pronounced
in the male's than the females but the
gray
here shows you the very clear
dose-response for the evidence of
increased inflammation and being
associated with problems with with
working memory okay I wanted to switch
here to talk a little more about
inherent susceptibility difference so
this is just a picture of of a group of
my employees here at NIU HS and if you
look at it you can tell that we're not
all the same and I think that's
something that we always have to
remember that there's tremendous
variability not only in how we look but
and how we respond to exposures so for
example we know that with arsenic's that
there are genetic polymorphisms in genes
related to the transport of arsenic into
the cells how arsenic is metabolized how
arsenic can produce oxidative stress and
how it damages DNA which is dependent or
can vary with certain different kinds of
alleles or certain genes we know that as
far as the food that we eat people
handle for example folate and vitamin C
some people can clear it or remove it
from their bodies very quickly others
can't and there can be tremendous
ditions and we know for example with the
microbiome that while we used to only
think of the bacteria in and on our
bodies as trouble we now realize that
the microbiome a healthy microbiome is
essential to our health is really a
synergistic interaction going on but the
microbiome can play a role in our
metabolism for example of arsenic so
some people whether it's because of
their genes or what they eat or their
bacterial content may handle some will
be more and some less sensitive to
arsenic now there's again a very
interesting study during northern Chile
in not in a Nevada but a neighboring
reasons where they found a population of
indigenous people who had a polymorphism
in this a s3m T gene which metabolizes
arsenic so it can be removed from the
body and they found that these people
were living in areas
very high arsenic in their drinking
water but did not have we're not showing
evidence of lung or bladder cancer and a
lot of that was because they were
getting rid of their arsenic very
quickly they found that the population
for example or you in this case they
looked at mestizos who were living in a
nearby area and they were said they
didn't have the altered gene and they
were susceptible and then this has also
been seen for example in a European
population and has also been seen in
Bangladesh now we also know that in
Bangladesh where I mentioned there has
been this problem in many areas of
Bangladesh with the two wells which led
to arsenic contamination of the water
people were drinking we found that the
number of copy numbers variations in
several genes led to an increase the
higher risk of arsenic into skin lesions
DNA copy number variations are being
shown to be associated many see and
these are being shown associated with a
variety of diseases I think the
important thing is we don't see this
effect in in women and it's only being
observed in men so that sex specificity
that I mentioned before and the copy
number variation is also present for
example when we look at the increased
risk of autism spectrum disorder and
early life exposure to ozone and if you
look at this four by four table what you
can see is for those individuals who
have a high number of copy number
variations which related to gene related
to autism plus have high levels of
exposure to ozone those are the people
at greatest risk of being on the autism
spectrum well as people who have low
ozone and no copy or very limited copy
number variation are essentially almost
not at risk for autism spectrum so I
think again the specificity is important
we also know that benzene that there are
differential susceptibility here and
genes are involved in metabolizing for
example benzene and matam
some gets rid of the active benzene
metabolite and so there's evidence that
for people who can get rid of benzene
very quickly they are going to be less
susceptible to the adverse effects of
benzene
now we're also finding for example that
the levels of different contaminants may
vary for example by race but sometimes
this may be related to food packaging so
these are looking at four different
pieces
this has c8 c9 and c10 and this one
instead of a carboxylic acid has a
symphonic acid at the end and what you
can see is that people who are eating a
lot of fast food from cardboard
containers which have been lined by
PFS contaminated material in this case
they are more likely to add elevated PFS
in their blood then in fact if they were
low consumers and the hypothesis is is
that these African American subjects
were just eating more fast food than for
example on the white subjects in the
study
now diazinon is another kind of
pesticide and again we're seeing more
another evidence of sex specificity here
this study was done in mice and there is
evidence here that there isn't on
authored the microbial community this is
another identify state in the gut of
mice and these changes were much more
pronounced in the male's where you can
see changes up to 2300 from 50 to 2300
as opposed to only 5 fold in the female
mice and again this may explain why the
male mice are more sensitive sensitive
to the neurological effects than 9 men
are females
now we also know there's a gene very
important in trying to detoxify
organophosphates and this is the gene
called pond 1 and we're showing that
people that there's polymorphisms in
this gene and people who are polymorphic
have more likely to suffer toxicity from
phosphate poisonings in one of our
longitudinal studies of a birth cohort
where we started started measuring
levels of exposure in the mothers while
they were pregnant and then continued to
follow them and their children we showed
that pond one does play a role in the
individual susceptibility and and we're
also showing that this may play a role
in the behavioural effects that we see
organophosphate can create so we believe
that by creating healthier environments
we are going to improve health we're
going to inform health protect the
policies and regulations our focus at
NIH s is on prevention we want to inform
intervention and remediation strategies
that promote behavior change you want to
build environment or health literacy
through outreach and education because
while we can't change our genes at least
not yet even with advances in CRISPR
cas9 we can change our environment and
by I mention one example before
regulations have an impact but for
example when EPA changed its drinking
water maximum contaminant level level in
2006 from 50 micrograms per liter to 10
what you can see is a decrease in the
levels of arsenic in urine in the
general population following that
reduction and that has impacts because
there's an estimated decrease the number
of cancer cases that could be associated
with arsenic exposure in ginseng water
educational interventions can also work
we're basically in Bangladesh the
children were taught in the school what
they needed to be conscious of like the
well handles that were bright red were
ones they should not get water from that
led to families switching to lower
switching to lower arsenic in their
waters so they have lower arsenic in
their urine as well and again those
where there was switch to have better
education did better this is a really a
beautiful example of improving air
quality and
for yourself there are a number of
examples here that we know that
reductions in p.m. decreases mortality
risk especially from hardened lung
problems we know that in Crete decreases
and nitrous oxide and PM lead to
increases better function and that's
actually this slide over here as the PM
concentration decreases what you can see
is that the measurements of lung
function the fev1 get better and again
this is following three cohorts of
eleven to fifteen year old children in
Southern California living in different
regions with different ethnic
backgrounds but as the air improved
around LA the children's lung function
the children who grew up with less air
pollution had better lung function than
the children who grew up with more
highly polluted air we can also work on
education to reduce the pesticide
take-home pathway I mentioned that
related to the children in Ecuador whose
parents were working in the flour
industry but we know that pesticides are
higher in homes and vehicles the
farmworkers compared to non farm workers
but we know that farm workers can reduce
their exposure by wearing gloves and
leaving their work clothes at work
before they return home so in summary
the interaction of our genes that our
environment determines our health
there's lots of role of individual
variability which influences our
biological response forensic
toxicologist environmental health
scientists were all trying to understand
how chemicals can affect human health
again as an environmental health
scientists and in fact psychologists I'm
often focusing on low dose chronic
exposure but by working together both
individually and some policy change we
can modify our environment to reduce
harmful exposures and improve our health
so thank you all and while I can't
answer questions directly now I'd be
very happy to receive emails and I'll be
happy to answer them so thank you all
I hope this
was helpful thank you dr. Birnbaum for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank lab risks for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder dr. Birnbaum will be
following up with any questions due to
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye